ce week-end c'est la twiri night race il
s'agit d'une première édition le
principe une course nocturne de 1 km à
10 km au cœur du parc zoologique de
Thoiry et des lumières sauvages pour en
parler Anthony Marie vous êtes
responsable de l'événementiel aux safari
de Thoiry alors après 3 éditions de La
Thoiry Wald race vous avez décidé de
détourner cette course en édition
nocturne pourquoi ce choix
très simplement puisque nous avons
depuis 5 ans maintenant les lumières
sauvages sur le zoo safari sa rencontre
un franc succès auprès de nos visiteurs
puisque maintenant l'hiver on fait
jusqu'à 200000 visiteurs supplémentaires
à notre activité habituelle donc on
s'est dit bien on a un cadre
exceptionnel pour faire une course donc
on l'a fait avec la Thoiry wine race
maintenant on va faire nos visiteurs en
plus une arrivée spectaculaire donc on
les mettant dans les lumières tout
simplement donc attention les lumières
c'est pas surtout le parcours il va
falloir ma maman avancer dans la nuit
frontale avec le dossard il fournit la
petite lampe vous en apporter un
exemplaire je vous l'offrir avec grand
plaisir si vous souhaitez et
particulièrement performante d'ailleurs
effectivement il y a des zones qui sont
totalement sombres ils vont aller dans
des endroits où pour la plupart des
coureurs et tout à l'heure vous a
receviez le le maire de Villepreux qui
est un adepte de la Thoiry ouest et il
sera présent à la torride night race
justement donc voilà on va le faire quoi
dans un endroit il n'a jamais couru
encore donc ceci c'est ça aussi un
spectacle visuel en fait pour les pour
les joueurs spectacle de visuel ça va
être alors ils vont pouvoir la faire
deux fois ils vont pouvoir le faire en
courant et puis on va profiter à la fin
de la course avec leur famille justement
de la visite des lumières sauvages donc
dans un temps un peu plus calme pour eux
justement et donc il y a plusieurs
parcours qui sont proposés de 1 km à 10
km est-ce que vous pouvez nous les
présenter c'est c'est du débutant au
plus confirmé en fait alors c'est
surtout une question d'âge on va déjà
commencer par là les enfants pour les
courses malheureusement on peut pas leur
mettre plus de kilomètres que un seul
kilomètre donc ils ont un petit parcours
qui va se faire quasiment deux jours
également la sécurité des enfants et
rassurer les parents ensuite on a un
parcours 5 km là on est sur du coureur
oui là on est sur du débutant là on est
sur du coup en débutant et puis ensuite
on est sur les un peu plus chinois sur
du 10 km j'insiste quand même on est
quand même pas sur du performeur il y a
quelques performeurs on va dire que le
peloton des 50 premiers ce sont des
coureurs et mérites ensuite l'intérêt
c'est vraiment d'être sur une course
familiale
à la fin avec des récompenses évidemment
on fait un classement c'est normal alors
vous avez déjà un cadeau qui est la
médaille de fin de course donc qui est
un modèle différent chaque année bien
sûr et puis celle-ci c'est l'édition
numéro 1 night race je l'offrirai aussi
si vous voulez
effectivement donc et puis après il y a
le classement pour les vainqueurs de
chaque étape donc bien sûr dans le
quatrième enfant car son fils ensuite
dans la 5 km femme homme et ensuite dans
la 10 km femme homme également donc il y
a effectivement des trophées le trophées
qui viennent en complément et alors vous
attendez combien de coureurs environ
ecoutez les inscriptions s'arrête ce
soir et on est à plus de 1700 coureurs
pour cette première édition donc je
pense qu'il va falloir commencer à
inscrire dans dans le temps cette course
nouvelle qui risque d'être dansante
jusqu'à ce soir minuit ce soir minuit
oui
et si vous n'arrivez pas à vous inscrire
ce soir vous envoyer un petit mail et
puis on arrivera à faire quelque chose
demain matin alors une partie des
bénéfices sera pour la sauvegarde des
animaux ça c'est primordial l'activité
événementielle que nous développons
depuis plusieurs années maintenant sur
le saut safari ne peut pas être
dissociée de l'activité principale de
notre métier qui est la préservation des
espèces donc on a à cœur que nous
événements Ali notre travail dans Zoo à
au travail réalisé sur les terrains et
donc nous avons la l'association Thoiry
conservation qui est indépendante de
Safari qui va donc percevoir une partie
effectivement de la quote-part des
dossards de manière à ce que ensuite cet
argent soit Ré attendez dans des
associations qui elles protègent animal
sauvage dans le milieu naturel ça vous
tente
la tordue plateau
allez 10 km mais oui pourquoi pas mais
c'est vrai qu'on se dit souvent qu'on
doit faire une courte tous ensemble mais
je pense que c'est peut-être un peu tard
mais quoique jusqu'à minuit mais on fait
des équipes s'il y a besoin on peut
faire les équipes il y a pas de souci
et chose importante on peut également
rajouter que la course on peut la faire
déguiser il y a pas de souci
et vous Julien police de course à pied
j'en faisais beaucoup effectivement
c'est j'aime bien les courses un peu
décalé comme ça un peu original
c'est totalement décalé et surtout ce
qui nous conforte dans l'idée de
continuer à faire des épreuves sportives
dans le zoo c'est le remerciement de la
part des coureurs et de leur famille
parce qu'effectivement en plus de la
course elle-même je pensais que le
coureur est plutôt un solitaire dans son
dans son sport là pour le coup il est il
est hué ou plutôt il est soutenu pardon
pour certains
par leur famille et leurs amis donc
c'est plutôt un moment sympathique de
partager et bien merci
si vous êtes intéressé vous pouvez
toujours vous inscrire du coup sur le
site internet qui s'affiche juste en bas
de votre écran thoiry.net le tarif et de
35 euros pour les 10 km 28 euros pour
les 5 km et 25 euros pour celles
d'environ un kilomètre